this is where a 19 year old football fan
was killed in the northern greek city of
thessaloniki
the street is now lined with candles and
flowers
alkish campanos was stamped to death
outside the aristosaloniki club stadium
he's believed to have been killed by
supporters of a rival team after a brawl
the case has led to a national debate
about violence at sporting events
we can't get over it my entire family
has been affected i have a 17 year old
grandson who wears the team's yellow
jersey all day and now we feel afraid
i'm 72 years old and i've been going to
the stadium since i was eight we never
had these types of
situations at least nine suspects have
been arrested but many say it's not
enough
the outrage is fueling calls for tighter
rules and punishment
under pressure the government announced
it will submit a bill in the coming
weeks to parliament with stricter
penalties and more police controls
combating violence among football fans
is an obligation we have towards greek
society the youth and the millions of
fans in our country in the past two
years significant steps have been taken
the government will continue in this
direction and we expect everyone in
society to contribute to eliminate
sports violence
the sport has been plagued by violence
on and off the field in recent years
these photographs of makeshift weapons
are among the items confiscated by
police a sign that the threat of
violence is always lurking and now the
murder of alkies is pushing the issue to
the forefront
i feel awful about it how can you not i
wonder what these people are thinking
how can they live it all seems
unthinkable all this violence taking
place
yellow jerseys of the adi's football
club have been placed in the
neighborhood where alkies was murdered
people here say it's a reminder to
authorities and the community of a
senseless tragedy
katie lopez al jazeera